joining me here now on the Rich Eisen
show via the good old zoom his gentlemen
I've been happy to say that I've known
for quite some time a die-hard fan of
the Raiders once upon a time from
Oakland in Los Angeles then Oakland
again now of the Las Vegas Raiders and
he will be part of a stand-up special
new Netflix comedy special Jorge Lopez
will do it for half that is streaming on
Tuesday June 30th only on Netflix the
man himself Jorge Lopez how are you sir
good to see rich but to see you too
how's life under this situation you know
I wish that we were all back to our
lives but that we understand that you
know that this takes precedence but it's
been it's been interesting I mean I
don't think I've had this time off since
I started doing stand-up really kind of
87 so it's been it's been an interesting
[Music]
few months of deciding whether when this
is resolved and how you know hopefully
we get out of it without losing too many
people that if I would even go back to
resuming a schedule that I had before
because as you get older you realize you
know do I really want to push this hard
after accomplishing you know pretty much
everything I've wanted to do you know I
love stand-up so much you know and and
in sports and analogies when somebody
says you know why are you doing stand-up
and you say you know what Muhammad Ali
have fought if he could fight til 59 I
mean would would somebody would Karima
played if he could be sharp at 59 right
if you could fly would you not fly so
you know those things go through my mind
when you think about I've never really
disconnected and if I do disconnect it's
so tough to connect against all you know
ring rust and situations and
you know has never been a shortage of of
things to talk about but I've enjoyed a
little bit of the solitude
well now that you're out I guess
promoting this special this special was
filmed at the Warfield Theatre in San
Francisco when did you do this
at what point what one woman did it last
December of exactly the 14th of December
and the Warfield you know I'm a huge I
mean nobody was a bigger historian of
their craft that Mike Tyson I mean you
every fight custom ATO had him sitting
in the room he was looking at Jack
Dempsey and and every great fighter he
knew their attributes he knew their
weaknesses and and they even had the
body you know would yell out 531 any
throw these combinations and stuff and
and the war filled with looking at
Nirvana in their Jerry Garcia's dressing
room as the main dressing room looking
at Janis Joplin looking at Jimi Hendrix
looking at Jerry Garcia of the Grateful
Dead and all the signatures you see on
the wall there you know they had closed
for renovations I believe and then they
opened up in 2007 and at 2007 they asked
me to be the first person to to open and
I did two shows and Carlos Santana came
us to see me a boo lead for one little
show then he sat in the audience he's
like you know I want to get a feel of us
like in the audience and then after the
show when the lights come on he was
trying to get out a sec and the balcony
he looked down and saw there Carlos
Santana was in the aisle and instead of
waiting to you know run and take the
stairs down right that dude jumped from
the balcony by maybe 15 feet and landed
at the feet of Carlos Santana to tell
him how big a fan he was and you know
they held him up to a speed they're like
hey bro you know and then I was
backstage when what happened to Carlos
or some dude jumped out of dumb Polly
and landed on his feet and it tripped
them out at home he loved the show I'd
say no patrons were harmed in the making
of those papers were harmed pretty good
drop man that is amazing and I imagine
right around then December of 2019
you know 49er mania was probably
gripping that town at that point time
and I don't know if you were able to
maybe take one more spin by the black
hole one more time I know if that was
going down for you in that time well I
don't think I don't think you know I
mean I'd like footballs awesome yes
the fact that I went to the I went to
the the Super Bowl with Carolina and and
and Denver but to see that to see the
stadium
way outside of San Francisco right is a
little bit of a you know I'm not I'm not
sure if I agree with the San Francisco
49ers not being in San Francisco
Candlestick clearly was not a place they
ever anticipated being there forever
like old it was cold I went there with
my grandparents to see the Dodgers and
the Giants play when Dave Kingman played
and then encountered Willie Davis fan
and he didn't play that that game and
they've gotten killed I remember seeing
the ball land in front of the outfielder
who might have been bond Joshua and it
bounced over his head and everybody
started laughing about 50 feet over his
head he ran in and okay it hopped in
front of the ball Stover's head went to
the wall and to see Sunday mornings and
not see families as I was leaving the
punchline to head back to LA to not see
families with the jerseys and
generations of people from the mission
area not being able to go to a game in
San Francisco just like I don't believe
that the Raiders leaving the field the
way they did I love Mark Davis I would
consider him a very good friend of mine
I don't think it was really the best
response to say that you're leaving
nothing you're not taking anything with
you as you go to Las Vegas the black
hole and what it meant to be a fan in
Oakland what
you have these fans that even through
the darkest times of Greater dumb still
looked at el Davis as a hero an icon a
beam of fire that they light every game
so them moving to Las Vegas is an
interesting play man and there's a lot
of people that as i sat there or went to
the black hole or hung around afterwards
and thought that one Sunday nobody's
going to be there and now that the
Warriors have gone to San Francisco
right and I don't know how they feel
about seiji new buildings but there are
a start at that stadium I'd bring in a
couple of shaman to come in and either
put sage in the dressing rooms around
the court because that place does not
have the vibe that Oracle had and then
it's all connected the multiplex of
where the ACE played and the Raiders
played right beautiful property there
but now you're taking two professional
teams out of a city like Oakland and
leaving them with the A's in an old
stadium and you know Dan the Green was
so long ago with Zeppelin and all the
bands that they stabbed there so it's
it's a little disheartening to know that
a city like Oakland that has been you
know a city of the Black Panthers of
culture of historical you know
situations that happen in such a great
city that they would be left with just a
reminder of the the teams and they're
the fans that you know would die for
would die for that team who is your guy
growing up who's the well your guy
George I mean George Blanda Daryle
Lamonica
Lyle Alzado I met at the the country
club in Reseda in the in the early
eighties when he was trying to come back
with the Raiders David Lee Roth used to
go to these boxing matches I was still
working during the days and on early 80s
I took a picture with Liao's later my
I'm around him and his bicep was what is
this maple you know and you know he's
laughing he took this picture with him
and I was at a birthday at his rib place
in Beverly Hills called RJ's and I saw
now I'll say to a month before he passed
walked down shakey with his headband on
and his wife taking him out and it was
it was it was really sad to see a dad
someone like that on and I and you're
like hey loud there's a say I'll I'll
you know and to see someone that damaged
from something that was so unproven that
he that the the idea of playing again
that you would risk your own life for a
season of an already amazing career
right so your those are your guys
growing up and it seems like so right
now you know you're not gonna follow the
team to Vegas you'll root for them you
you know III listen I you go work I mean
I was at the groundbreaking with out
with mark and you know the Commissioner
okay Tana was there Wayne Newton it
gives you an idea already that what you
know of the fact that you you can be on
the field and be the Imperial Palace and
see you know I made a joke I said you
know four kickers everything breaks
towards Excalibur oh the idea is that
that that you you know one of the things
that was great about cities that had
stadiums is you could see and should at
Wrigley you could see at places
neighborhoods and those things you know
a breeding at Fenway and Men likes
before Wrigley and now they put up
pretty much awnings and seats where you
charge people who live across the street
they don't have the access that they
used to have and you know sports was
never really about the money until you
realize that it was all about the money
Oh short and you see that debt it looks
like the Death Star I mean it looks that
I mean like thatthat see this is exactly
what Al Davis thought you know if they
could move this if this team somewhere
and build a Death Star
literally
looks like it's gonna shoot a beam out
it rebels come in to try and win whole
black lacquer look the whole onyx type
feel
you know the t-mobile Arena looks like a
pot that you they bring you steamed rice
steamed rice in when you're at a
Japanese or Chinese restaurant like that
all you wanted rice it's it looks like
it's a bamboo thing that you put rice on
top everybody just dig into this rice so
clearly the NHL works in Las Vegas but
maybe I don't believe that right the
Clippers belong in Los Angeles the
Clippers became the Clippers in San
Diego because the Yankee Clipper or the
Clippers be sailors but when you cover
up 16 banners with players on the on the
Clippers when the Clippers share the the
arena or Staples Center with is
disingenuous to a team that's won 16
championships I don't think anybody
would ever dare to go to whatever the
Boston Garden is now and put banners
over the championship Celtic banners
well look man I'm looking forward to
seeing your special give give everybody
what the what a little taste of what to
expect when they when they stream it's
just more the same just a good
old-fashioned classic George Lopez this
is your I've created an uncle alter-ego
that you know I had these uncles it's a
combination of all of them that you know
they told my uncle not to drink you know
you have heart disease you have a gang
dress right foot you have a liver
cirrhosis of the liver you drink you die
and I saw my uncle go to the doctor oh
you know nobody heckles a doctor and he
drank he lost his foot they were taking
called over like pick a part say if
somebody needs a knee they're gonna take
his knee and it is it is about a little
bit of what's going on now with some
immigration stuff it's all the family
stuff and it's a little bit ridiculous
to think that we all need to know where
our food came from you know if they
saturday they're these tortillas are
handmade they're like who's hands today
was the chicken
mainly put down and put down you know
giving CBD oil to my rescue dogs all of
the things that I think at this
particular time in the middle of the
summer I think it'll be a special
that'll be very well received as the
screeners have started to go out I've
gotten a lot of great feedback from
people that I would not have expected
great feedback from because comedy is a
business where everybody thinks that
they're better than everybody else they
find it hard to give somebody a
compliment when I used to think that the
fact that all these Latino comedians
would never say you know I was inspired
by a George Lopez when clearly I was
doing it while they were still in
elementary school so I would I don't
need the confirmation because I've
pretty much have done everything I ever
aspired to do sort you just playing with
house money now rich well who was before
I let you go who is on tour who was out
there with you in 87 when you started
who's happening with you who you're
opening for or who are you who did well
I started in 1979 I put my job at 87 so
when 79 Jay Leno was there David
Letterman wore a ball all University
t-shirt he drove a pickup truck two
women from the comedy store Garry
Shandling was at The Comedy Store in
Westwood Howie Mandel Kim tomerson Yakov
Smirnoff Pryor I remember when we were
there we heard this incredible commotion
coming from the main room and Robin
Williams was on says the openers door
Robin was on stage in his Mork & Mindy
costume he must have came from paramount
you know I suspenders and the pants and
you know bra Seinfeld
Arsenio Richard Pryor I saw idly Nana in
a yellow corniche Rolls Royce in front
of the comic store by himself listening
to this set on a microcassette recorder
just the greatest period of time out in
in a 18 year old Chicano from the San
Fernando Bellies life I could not have
asked for even though I didn't know him
I could not have asked to see better
representation of comedy I met de
Gregorio
Big Sean I became friends of Richard
Pryor I know Chris Rock Eddie Murphy and
I are friendly and then Arsenio and I've
been friends for 31 years so as a fan of
it I never thought I was better than
anybody I just just wanted to be me and
to know all these guys and to know
musicians the way I know musicians and
to just be able to you know play golf
and played golf with Scottie Pippen
yesterday at Lakeside to see to see
these guys and and golf has been a great
way to do that it's it's not a bad life
rich it sure is what did you talk to
Scotty about the last dance documentary
you know and we talked a little bit
about the last days a guy was talking to
him about the guy who invented the
barcode that owns a tremendous amount of
property in Chicago a tremendous car a
collection two buildings and they said
like generally goes this guy boasted a
little most of those got to see if
you're selling cards but we're a little
bit about the last dance not a lot about
about it you know I realized that you
know I want to be left alone
but hey when Michael Jordan when he left
we said you know if Michael Jordan says
that none of this would have been
accomplished by not having Scottie
Pippen at my side you realized that the
greatest arguably one of the greatest
players to ever play basketball says
that I would not have done what I did
without having the guy who shot 97 by my
side that's right hey you're the man
George thanks for the time yeah matters
great together on the regular now that
in though it took 13 years to I know it
took a long time but at least we better
late than never Joe you got it George
Lopez will do it for half can be
starting stream on the 30th Tuesday
streaming on Netflix only that's George
Lopez here in the Rich Eisen show